I know it's uh it's early at least for
me because I I'm nine hours uh have nine
hours of jet lag but I hope to not bore
you to death but this talk can give you
some context like why I came to care so
much about this project and maybe some
ways that you might think about you know
getting involved in infrastructure
technology for for data science and and
data engineering or ways that you can
support and and you can take advantage
of this take advantage of this work so a
little over a little over ten years I
started writing some Python code for
myself to wrangle wrangled data
I never expected I didn't really know
much about open source or expected to
turn into a very big project and so so
the last you know years have been really
interesting I spent a lot of my time
from 2011 and in 2011 2012 really
focused on building the the pandas
project but about five years ago I
handed over the reins of the project to
the rest of the the rest of the
maintainer is people whose names names
you may or may not have heard of people
like Jeffrey vac and your and and Bosh
Tom Alex Berger Philip cloud folks
who've been you know really building the
project out and making the community
healthy over the last last five years
but I got busy with some other projects
that are you know closely related to
pandas but not not exactly pandas itself
probably a lot of you have might have a
copy of my or some of you have a copy of
my book which is you know almost in it's
almost you know came out six years ago
this or six years ago in October so as
Pete was he was mentioning funding
open-source projects is difficult and I
think lately there's there's a general
feeling in the air around funding
maintenance of large established
projects so in the wake of you know
really major security
vulnerabilities and important software
like many maybe you know a lot of you
probably heard about heartbleed and like
it was a major bug in open SSL and after
people dug in they're like well who
maintains open SSL and it turns out that
open SSL only had one full-time
maintainer and the other maintainer is
were working part-time and we're all
kind of stressed out that you know they
could have security bugs but they just
don't have enough funding to support
support the project so a lot of people
have been working on how can we get
corporate sponsorship to maintain really
critical software so if you if you think
about open source software as a public
good in the sense that you know we have
clean water and roads and you know
sewers like maybe we should take the
same approach to you know essentially
individuals companies and governments
funding development of open source
infrastructure it's not such a crazy
idea but raising money - and having
money to build brand-new projects is
even more difficult because you have to
convince people that you can actually
build the project and that it will be
valuable and so so I've been building
something new the last few years and so
I earlier this year I created an
organization called Ursa labs - to focus
on building the building the arrow
project with the with the focus on
creating shared infrastructure for for
data science to accelerate to accelerate
data science and data engineering and
python r and kind of across the spectrum
of tools that data scientists use so to
do this I I partnered with with our
studio and and Hadley welcome because I
wanted the you know I guess kind of in
the data science world were two of the
most well known people in that in that
ecosystem and I wanted to have the the
our community you know bought in and and
committed to working together to to
build you know software that we can all
use in both both programming languages
but it's certainly not limited to to
just Python and R but that's a pretty
good place a pretty good place to start
I had been working at two sigma for the
last couple of years so there
they're a financial institution in New
York City they're continuing to kind of
sponsor the project so you know our
studio is committed to committed
resources and I expect to be adding some
additional logos to this to this page
over over the next six months so if your
company or any any companies that you
work with would be interested in
sponsoring this work we'd be happy to
hear from you but our goal with what the
money that we're raising is to hire
people and have them work full-time
doing 100% open-source development so
not doing consulting not building
products or any of those things which
tend to distract from the core open
source development and doing a good job
of building high-quality production
software so so one one problem that I
encounter I've encountered over the
years is the fact that data systems are
highly fragmented when you look under
the hood at the tools that they use to
you know to implement themselves so
things like how is data stored how is
data deserialized how is data
represented in memory
who wrote the algorithms to compute
things on that on that data and memory
and so a lot of systems are black boxes
that are very vertically integrated so
pandas is one such system that's highly
vertically integrated where you know
we've wrote rewrote our own CSV parser
our own way to read data out you know
read data from hdf5 files you know
reading data from databases we have you
know we have our own kind of query query
engine pandas is kind of its own kind of
in-memory database kind of thing we have
our own front-end which and the the
front-end could the Python code that you
write is tightly coupled to to the
backend but it's it's a complicated
thing and you know one of one of the
issues is that we don't have a lot of
open standards so open standards help
with making things simpler by using
common technology that makes systems
interoperable and makes things makes
things less fragmented and so for me
that the two things I'm most interested
in is sharing data without having to
copy or
realize and sharing code so being able
to take an algorithm that somebody else
wrote in being able to run it on my data
without having to rewrite the algorithm
and those two things historically are
very difficult so we have we have lots
of open standards already you know if
you're in the Big Data world you might
be familiar with some of the storage
formats like parquet and orc that have
come out of out of the Hadoop ecosystem
there's things like hdf5 for storing
general numeric data sets we have
general structure data serialization
tools for for RPC so Avro came out of
the Hadoop world we also have protocol
buffers and thrift which is I understand
I don't know the history but I think
thrift was created by X Googlers who
wanted to have an open-source version of
protocol buffers and then Google open
source protocol but first so now we just
have lots of you know incompatible tools
some people think of CSV as being an
open standard but it's not because
there's no standard way of serial I
guess there is there there are some
standards for writing down schemas for
CSVs but the amount of variety and
different options and parsing CSVs makes
makes them a poor choice for for
warehousing for warehousing data so
given that we have lots of fairly it's
standardized standardized accepted ways
of serializing binary data we don't have
a lot of standards for in-memory data
and so if you want to share algorithms
that execute against in-memory data you
need to have open standards for
in-memory the only the main one that we
have is the multidimensional array model
which came out of basically APL and
fortran so when people you know when
folks built MATLAB and they built numpy
they already had a memory model for
representing multi-dimensional arrays
like okay here's a data pointer
here's shape and Strides to instruct the
code how to iterate over interpret a
block of memory as being a
multi-dimensional a multi-dimensional
array but when you have when you have a
a standard memory model that means that
two processes can move data through
shared memory without without any
conversions or copying you can send data
through a socket receive it on the other
side without performing any additional
conversions outside of the socket send
and receive if somebody writes an
algorithm you can invoke that algorithm
in a different context so that's how
we've been able to reuse you know
decades worth of linear algebra code
written in the 70s and 80s a lot of it
still a lot of it's still in Fortran if
you're in the Java world you can you
know you can create bindings to C in C++
code and invoke assuming all the data
and all feet memory you can invoke
algorithms that are written in C and C++
on data that was generated by by the JVM
so you get lots of good benefits when
when you standardize in memory but when
you go beyond multi-dimensional arrays
to you know tables and data frames
essentially so if you're if you're a
data scientist probably use data frames
I guess everything has data frames now
spark has data frames you know pandas
has data frames are as data frames
Giulia you know every language has a
data frame but when you look under the
hood of what's inside the data frame in
almost every case the internals are
different and not and not compatible and
this creates a lot of problems so in the
context of a database system suppose
that you want to extend a database
system with some custom code that is
written in Python or written in R so
because there because the the in-memory
format of the database the way it
represents data in its runtime is not
it's not public so there's no public API
for the internal data what they do is
they define an intermediate API for
writing extensions and then serialize
from their internal representation to
that intermediate representation and
expose that to you as a public API that
API is often row based and so if you're
a Python programmer you don't want to be
running one Python function call for
every row in a billion row dataset
that's going to be
you know ridiculously slow so you know I
arrived in the Big Data world at the end
of 2014 after after having a startup I
was at Cloudera I looked around so we've
got to make Python in our first class
citizens in the big data world how do we
do that and you know my feeling after
assessing the ecosystem was well we have
to solve this problem so that we can
make data available to the data science
world without having to go through a
very narrow kind of serialization pipe
so so 1 1 1 there's a number of reasons
why I think that there things are so
fragmented and there there has not been
a prior effort to create standardization
so one I mean one thing is just open
source communities are fragmented by
their nature like it's sort of an
anarchy there's no central government
making decisions very it's very
infrequent that you see developers from
different communities come together so
I've started spending more time with the
our community our community historically
has not spent much time talking to other
communities the same with Python and
others so you can't really you know
blame communities for you know focusing
on their own needs and developing
solutions for the problems that are
right in front of them I also think that
some of the fragmentation is caused
because people want to make the front
end the user API for these projects they
want to make it work exactly like in a
particular way so even within our
there's the tidy verse and there's data
table and there's base are and part of
the reason why there's so many different
there's different data frame API s and R
is because the user experience of using
those libraries is completely different
even though the underlying you know data
is just an R and our data frame in a
Python the pandas API is also a lot
different from from the our data frame
the our data frame API but there's a lot
of details of the way that pandas is
implemented
that are visible in the public API so if
we wanted to change make major changes
to the internals that would cause API
breaks that would upset upset users and
we've just made the decision to like try
not to upset users very much although I
don't know that we've succeeded at all
at all times so kind of in response to
this I I spent a lot of 2015 going
around the the open source Big Data
world it was a bit Bay Area centric
because that's where you know that's
where I was physically at the time and
where I could meet with people in person
and see if they were interested and
working on working on this effort and we
were able to assemble a collection of
about 25 people who are leaders in
different open-source data science and
Big Data projects to commit to working
together to creating an open standard
for in-memory data frames that's calm
oriented and suitable for analytic
computing and for me what's really
exciting about this and I'm gonna tell
you more about in the next you know 20
minutes or so is that I wanted to create
the environment that would enable
collaboration between the data science
world and the database systems world or
historically they've been completely
separate and there's a lot of really
great technology that's in the database
world but very little of that technology
has made its way into data science the
only way the data scientists get access
to that is by sending sequel queries
into a database and so I would like to
see like to see that change so kind of
to recap our our goal the goal is to go
from having non portable data formats to
portable data formats so that's that's
kind of the arrow format which I'm gonna
tell you more about and my objective is
to create libraries high quality
libraries that handle the kinds of
problems that you solved with pandas and
with equivalent libraries and other
languages that are reusable and can be
ported and built and you can use via
binding layers and many different
programming languages
so if you think about this in the
context of analytic databases so
traditionally a database system or a
data science library is is vertically
integrated so your front-end is usually
sequel queries and when the sequel query
is parsed you the database creates a
logical query plan it looks at
statistics and metadata about how the
data is stored and what what we know
about the data it creates a physical
query plan that query plan is executed
by a computation engine which might be
single node it might be distributed that
computation executes against you know
data that's in memory which may be
deserialized from disk on the fly or it
may be cached in memory and so that's
where the in-memory format comes in and
then we have IO subsystems for
interacting with file systems for
reading and writing file formats but
usually all of this is is not is not
visible to external users so you only
see the front end and the internals are
deliberately made kind of part of the
black box and so if you want it to
extract code and reuse it it would be
very very difficult so so our goal is to
kind of deconstruct you know the
analytic database to break things into
libraries that have public api's that
are reusable and you can pick and choose
the components that you want to use to
build a data processing system so if you
just want so if you just want a fast you
know data access and deserialization
layer you can use that if you want you
know a way to share memory between
processes a lot like deal with large
data sets on disk you can just use that
if you just want to use the library of
algorithms and the memory format you
know it's sort of up to you but the big
picture is that we don't want to be
prescribing the API and the way the
front end the way that you interact with
the data so if you want it to be sequel
you can make it sequel if you want it to
be pandas like or are like you can
create an API that works like data
frames and those in those languages so
you know deconstructed
deconstruct a database deconstructed
soup it's kind of that's sort of our
goal so the so the project the the use
case is that we're concerned with our or
at least that I'm concerned with are
these three areas so the first is being
able to have very fast access to data so
being able to read and write data in all
of the ways that it is stored so that's
dealing with storage formats like
columnar park' files it's being being
able to you know read and write data as
efficiently as possible to database
systems because we can't just take all
the data out of whoever it's stored and
say okay we've got a new data format
it's not even a storage format it's an
in-memory format so we can't you know we
can't move the data but we need to get
access to the data as quickly as
possible from wherever it's stored if
you have data that is in Aero format we
we want to be able to move around data
sets between processes and nodes as
efficiently as possible so the two areas
that we're focused on they're a shared
memory and RPC so socket based
communication and then if it would be it
would be kind of useless if you couldn't
actually do anything with the data as is
if you just needed to convert it to some
other representation all the time so
we're also developing computational
libraries that evaluate natively against
the arrow format so let me see I need to
move
I added some slides and then I forgive
me
so the so the arrow format itself is a
an in-memory table like format for
representing data frames or representing
a fragment of a table like a chunk of
the table inside a sequel engine it's
arranged it the way that the data is
arranged in memory is optimized for
analytical processing so you wouldn't
want to use it to build a mutable row
store necessarily but if you were
building a columnar analytic database
engine that's that's what it's designed
for
you can represent both flat and nested
data and it works well on both CPUs and
GPUs and we have people actively using
the format on both types of types of
hardware so when you perform analytic
operations you only document because
it's columnar you only access the data
that is relevant for your algorithms and
the access patterns to scan scan columns
are efficient for the processor so we
we've had a couple of things built in
the last in the last couple of years to
help demonstrate kind of the benefits of
using having more efficient more
efficient data interchange and data and
data transport so in SPARC 2.3 SPARC 2.3
ships with optional optional Aero
support which you can use in in PI spark
and the the idea is that I'll go back to
the results here is that spark sequel
has its own internal representation of
tabular data in inside spark sequel
spark data frames depending on you know
what part of SPARC you're using they
could either be spark data frames or or
just general sparks equal but SPARC
sequel does it's data is not resident
and shared memory so you can't do a true
zero copy sharing between between
processes so if you wanted to make a
large data set available to a Python
process maybe this is changing but at
least as far as you know with my
up-to-date knowledge I don't think it's
possible but the way that it works is
that spark sequel serializes data to the
arrow columnar form
that is streamed to the PI spark worker
process it's converted again to pandas
but then we built a layer to evaluate
native pandas code against data like
chunks of data that are coming from
spark and then this is streamed back to
spark via via the arrow format and you
might say to yourself well this is crazy
like we have for serialization steps
like we have to convert from sparks
internal format to arrow format then to
pandas then run some pandas code then
convert back back to arrow don't you
know to arrow and then from arrow so we
have for serialization steps so that
can't possibly be efficient but you have
to remember like what like where did we
start and so there was already a
multi-step serialization process that
was happening but that serialization
format was particular to the spark pi
spark bridge and even with all of the
serialization going on the efficiency
you know with the efficiency of the
arrow format these are some sample
user-defined functions that our pandas
faced you know in some cases we're able
to get more than a 100 X speed-up and
evaluating custom custom Python codes so
if you see here on the left
suppose that you wanted to run you know
you compute the cumulative cumulative
probability function for a normal
distribution inside sparks equal you can
write that using Syfy stats and when
you're using Python all of these all of
these functions that you have for
analytics are supposed to be they're
intended to be invoked on numpy arrays
and so you can use them on pandas
objects as well but if you were to so
the ideal mode is to invoke these
functions on a thousand rows on a
thousand values at a time or a million
or a billion values at a time not to run
them once for every row and a data set
so even though we have all of this
serialization work to do to move the
data tune from Python the efficiency
gains are coming largely from changing
the execution model from row base to
vector base and so batching the
user-defined function evaluations
so that's cool
another thing we are another thing we're
developing actively right now in case
this is relevant to you is a an RPC
framework for building data services so
if you have a system and you want to be
able to send around large data sets this
is a framework for defining custom
custom data services we're using G RPC
which is you know kind of become the the
gold standard open source RPC framework
created by created by Google the
protocol is uses protocol buffers and so
if you know about protocol buffers you
might say well protocol buffers you have
to parse them and so how do we avoid
that well we spent some time doing some
low-level optimizations in in G RPC so
that we can receive chunks of data from
from the server and interpret them as
being Aero data sets
without having to do any any additional
parsing so let's see here so I kind of
want to make this this whole thing real
to explain kind of how this zero copy
thing works so I'm just gonna since I
don't have a lot of time just kind of
skip to the punchline but um all right
all right so here on my my local disk I
have an 11 gigabyte file
I hope this item actually haven't tried
this demo today so maybe it doesn't work
because you know open-source but so 11
gigabyte file it contains a stream of
table chunks that I I wrote in one in
one stream to disk so we have like the
notion of streaming data so which has to
be written from start to end there also
we also have a way to store data on disk
that you can do random access and read a
block from from middle of the table and
so so what we can do in Python is memory
map that file open the stream and then
read all of the stream as as a table and
so reading that reading that entire 11
gigabyte file only takes about 10
milliseconds and now we have a table in
memory that has let's see 400 million
rows and I can I can access a column and
then access any any row in the data set
so if I want the thousandth row or the
10 million the 10 million throw there
happen to all be the same in this case
but so I can do random access on on this
this giant data set and so in the
context of you know streaming RPC where
a table is sending you batches of data
so what you can do is when you receive a
chunk of data from the server you can do
whatever you want with it you can buffer
it in memory you can stream it to a file
so suppose that a server sends you an
unknown amount of data and possibly more
data than you have RAM available you can
put all that data on disk and then
memory map it and then proceed with your
with your analysis so compared with the
way that like pandas handles data this
is like a totally totally new world so
if you had associate if you would
implemented a the RPC framework is
called flight and so if you had built a
server implementation there's many
different architectures you could you
could do you could have a planner node
which
you know tells you like which servers to
get the day at the whole dataset from it
might be distributed across many servers
the planner and the the server with the
actual data might be the same server so
there's many different ways you could
set it up but you request info about a
data set which is called called a flight
and then you perform a series of gets to
the underlying nodes that contain the
data and so those could be serial or
parallel and so just in the last month
or so we've created an implementation of
this and in C++ and so in Python I'm
able to move around about three
gigabytes per second with a single
thread on localhost and that includes
kind of end to end push data through the
socket receive on the other side and
have it ready to go kind of memory
mapped in in memory so it's a very a lot
of cool stuff are possible with this so
if you have if we have any data protocol
nerds in the audience so the way that
things work under the hood is when you
make a request to the to the server a
data set get requests it uses a G RPC
stream to send a sequence of row batches
back to the back to the client and so
each of those row batches might be a
thousand rows or a million rows you know
depending on how you set things up and
even though the the data is transported
in a protocol buffer with some
additional metadata we built we were
able to write a custom deserialize ER
for G RPC both in Java and in C++ to be
able to receive that that payload and
avoid doing any extra copying of the the
memory inside the protocol buffer so
that we can interpret it as an arrow as
a narrow dataset so so kind of our goal
in building this this technology is to
create something that is high quality
very general purpose and that you can
take and put and use it as a library
inside existing existing systems so when
you're building it with somebody doing
RPC so we've sort of said you know we
don't care about what kinds of commands
you execute you can define custom
commands
your clients and servers so you could
create a custom command that executes
the sequel query so this is a protocol
buffer definition that contains a URI
for a database and a query you can send
that in a you know get info RPC with
type command and then the server if it
understands that command will send you
back instructions how to retrieve the
results of that query but the kinds of
commands you could send is really it's
up to you you can implement whatever you
whatever you like so so that's some
stuff that's going on in the project
just in you know just in recent times
but we've been in development for almost
almost three years now we have almost
200 unique contributors one of the areas
that in terms of you know bringing
building a large community of users is
that we've been trying to support as
many programming languages as possible
we're now up to ten programming
languages not all of them are have a
fully complete you know set of
functionality so some of them are native
implementations so we have a native
implementation in C++ Java JavaScript
also in rust and go and the rest are the
rest are bindings and so so in Python we
interact with the C++ libraries directly
there's folks in in Japan in the Ruby
community who are working on Ruby
bindings to this tech and they're going
through a C binding layer and but yeah
so we're kind of essentially adding as
many programming languages as we can and
making sure that we're giving you know
enabling people to access the data and
access the libraries to be able to use
those inside their systems another
project that's that's going on that's
that's pretty interesting is a
expression compiler for creating higher
performance analytic functions that
evaluate against tables and data frames
so this came out of the drum EO
corporation which there
building an open-source project called
remya which is a kind of federated data
access layer its sequel based it's
written in Java and they wanted to
accelerate the evaluation of the
expressions that are found in the select
part of a sequel query and the where
parts essentially projections and
filters and even though their system is
written in Java they it created a
compiler for these expressions that uses
LLVM so it's invoked from C++ and
because there's a common memory format
in Java and C++ that data can be exposed
to the to the Gandiva compiler runtime
through J&I without actually copying the
memory because it's just memory
addresses that are you know coming out
of off heap JVM memory so it's kind of
always been the dream and my dream to be
able to have zero copy data sharing
between of complex datasets between the
JVM and the native code world and I
guess it's only taken you know it's only
taken me 10 years to get here but I'm
glad that we were I'm glad that we're
finally that we're finally getting there
some more use cases but um there's
another exciting thing that's going on
so last year
Nvidia got together a group of companies
that are building a group of companies
that are building and doing analytics on
the GPU either building databases that
run on the to do interactive analytics
on the GPU companies like you might have
heard of like map D there's another
company called graph history doing kind
of in browser graph exploration and
visualization that's GPU powered and the
idea was to create libraries of reusable
analytic functions for for CUDA to
enable first of all to enable data to be
shared between one GPU based system and
another and have a standard library of
algorithms for performing doing feature
engineering and data for a data frame
operations on data on the GPU so they've
called this the GPU data frame it's
so essentially arrow on the GPU and you
know the kinds of things that are
possible now is that you can run a
sequel query in map D which is a GPU
based database you can ask map D to
leave that data the results of the query
on the GPU that that data can be made
available to another process using kudos
built-in inter process communication so
CUDA IPC you can get it get a handle to
that data in Python and then write
custom code in Python compile it with
numba which is using lov m and then run
that directly on the data set in the GPU
and this is the kind of thing that if
you didn't have a common data
representation this just would not be
this would not be possible not be
possible at all so very cool stuff
happening here as time has gone on I
guess the number of companies and folks
who are you know contributing or using
you know using arrow has expanded you
know there's some folks so one of the
components of the project is a is a
system for managing shared memory
regions that's used in the Ray machine
learning project which is out of the the
rise lab at UC Berkeley and so we've had
folks from kind of a leap a at ant
financial contributing to the project
which is you know really cool since you
know I think you know the running joke
is always you know somebody from
California you know meet somebody from
China and they're like oh yeah we have
big data and they say well we've got you
know this is China we've got you know
content probably ten times as much data
as as you do so I think you know getting
you know contributions from you know
from folks different you know from folks
in China is really important for
ensuring that these systems are you know
scalable to you know to kind of that
level of data sizes
sorry I don't want to overwhelm you with
technical detail but um so anyway
Sather you can tell this is stuff that
I'm I'm very excited about a lot of
people it's how much time I have like
what five minutes yeah five or ten
minutes yeah I'll make some time for
some some questions but um a lot of
people ask me like Wes like how can i
you know how can I use the software like
how is this relevant to me and it really
depends so in so if you're a data
scientist or a data engineer so my
objective over the next you know I've
been working on this project for about
three years and you know I have there's
easily you know three or four more years
of work that that I want to do on it but
there's one area which is I would like
to deliver an era natively Aero based
kind of next-generation data frame
library that is a companion project to
pandas that's designed for working with
very large data sets
it has memory mapping you know built-in
is it's like key feature so you can have
treat data on disk as though it's in
memory so if you have hundreds of
gigabytes of data on disk you can
perform meaningful analytics on your
laptop without having to spin up a spark
cluster okay that came back because I
think it is sort of sad that that you
know at the level at you know pandas
wasn't really designed for working with
massive data sets and so to have five or
ten gigabytes of data and be unable to
perform joins and memory and have to you
know write a Hadoop job or write a spark
job it makes me sad and I think part of
the problem is that data science systems
don't aren't internally are not
architected like databases so they they
don't have query planners if you join
two data frames and then want to
immediately filter and aggregate there's
no way for pandas to be able to optimize
and evaluate that efficiently that's
something that we could build
of the context of pandas so but I'd like
to build all of this in a way that is
not Python specific so so the art
community can take advantage of kind of
improved you know computational
internals for data frames folks in the
Ruby world can and can use that as well
anyone who wants to build bindings to
those libraries can can take advantage
of them I think with the work on like
faster RPC and messaging I think we will
see a wave of a lot of systems
deprecating their existing data access
and RPC layers in favor of natively
natively Aero based messaging so you
know to be able to move multiple
gigabytes per second through a socket
and that's kind of end to end you know
you know traditionally messaging layers
might you might get a few hundred
megabytes per second so to have a 10 10
X you know you know 5 to 10 X
improvement in throughput improves you
know resource utilization you know it
removes a lot of the serialization time
that's spent in distributed systems so
it's a clear clear win in terms of cost
savings inside inside data centers and
you know I honestly envision a world
that is is built around the notion of
data micro services where you have a
centralized metadata registry you can
see like here's all of my data services
available I used the exact same client
interface to access all of them and you
can push and pull datasets at high at
high speed in a you know in a cloud or a
kind of cluster cluster environment but
right now it's it's it's difficult
because you use different clients to
access data you have to think about
how's the data stored is it a park'
files Avro is it you know is it CSV like
what library do I use like what settings
do I use with that library like how do i
parse the dates you know it does this
have missing data how is this missing
data represented in memory so there's
like you know as a data scientist you
know data scientists are overwhelmed
personally I'm overwhelmed with like all
of the complexity and things that people
have to worry about just to deal with
like I want
read a data set I want to perform some
simple analytics and feature engineering
and then use tensor flow and there's so
many there's so much you know stuff you
have to deal with to get to the point of
actually doing you know not like the
actual science so I would like to
simplify that as much as possible and
just make it about you know I request a
data set I get the data set as fast as
possible I don't have to worry so much
about all these details and I can get on
with my my work as a data engineer or
data scientist
so hopefully that sounds hopefully that
sounds good but you know I think to
build technology like this that that
kind of makes things less fragmented and
and it helps unblock these these use
cases is a great deal of work so you
know people often ask me logo how long
am I gonna have to wait but you know I
think the next few years are going to be
you know pretty impactful in terms of
getting the software deployed in many
places and in production and beginning
to make things you know faster and
simpler so thanks for thanks for
listening I guess maybe you have five
minutes for four questions could you
talk about schema evolution in the the
format please yeah so though so the
format is well so first of all it's not
for it's not for long-term storage so
it's for ephemeral sorts for ephemeral
ephemeral ephemeral storage and and kind
of you know for data transport but I
guess the question might be suppose I
have an old server or sending data to
you know sending data to a new a new
client so in the case that you have well
the case I was talking about is you had
that disk on that file on disk that area
file let's say you have a different
schema with several different files yeah
oh that I mean that's that that's a
temporary file so that you wouldn't want
to you know you wouldn't want to store
that on HDFS and then come back and read
it seven years seven years later so it's
in the event that you're you know in the
event that your schema changes
well I mean you can look at me you can
look at the two schemas and project one
one to the other we haven't written the
you know the projection code so like
hypothetically you could say you know
here's the schema I want now and read
this file but conform you know when
there if there's a new column that isn't
on on disk then that column would have
show up is all nulls in the result but
yeah the schema is yeah the schema is
stored with the data so you can look at
the schema and decide what you want to
do hi thanks for talking to us today
I was just wondering about you you
mentioned two Sigma's your early
collaborator or some sort of like
contributor can you elaborate them that
a little bit and maybe talk about
specific use cases or applications of
era in the hedge fund industry in
general thank ya well yeah I guess I
can't I can't speak specifically to what
2 Sigma is doing with their data but
they but 2 Sigma has a has a petascale
data warehouse and invests a lot of time
and money in in data you know in data
collection has acquired companies that
specialize in data collection and I
think that they view one of their most
valuable sources of intellectual
property is their data itself heavy
spark user a heavy enough spark user
that they actively contribute to spark
and have done significant internal
developments to make spark easier to use
in a kind of multi tenant setting and a
lot in kind of large cloud and
on-premise ters but they're also a heavy
Python user and so the reason that I the
reason that I went to work there is with
it is essentially the promise of making
Python on spark a lot better which we
did successfully do and so you know so
my colleague Legion a to Sigma did that
work in collaboration with IBM
and you know they they're also a big
Java shop and so the kind of improved
interoperability between the Java JVM
ecosystem and the native code world is
is very interesting for companies like 2
Sigma that have large you know jut large
Java based systems
you